hey gang real quick before we get the
old show started let's talk about these
live days we got coming up
it's the keep it moving 2021 tour
and we're coming to a town near you
we're gonna be
in atlantic city new jersey june 18th oh
yeah and then we're going to be in
chicago
for our fourth and final show on june
22nd
then we're heading over to indianapolis
indiana
at the helium over there on june 23rd
get some tickets
and then we're coming back thursday
night back to the windy city
for two sold out shows so if you heard a
date on there
that wasn't sold out buy some tickets
and come see us
it's gonna be a great time yeah guys the
live show's awesome it's stand up and
then we play ayg
with the audience we answer your
questions it's a good [ __ ] time get
involved
see you there oh baby welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage sure is little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians we find out they grow up to be
classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a glorious day
we're down here in aunt tooty's basement
i gotta say
our guest got me a little nervous i'm
sliding off the stool
the kid's a looker but we're not there
yet
i got bozo sitting next to me my main
just as good looking some say better
kevin james ryan everybody no only my
mom hey what's up okay
this is a silly one already thanks for
tuning in uh as always please make sure
you review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube and as you
know those numbers are
true true to roof those numbers are
cooking baby and then
the bread and butter the money maker
patreon.com
are you garbage love that money closing
in on 1500 people
we [ __ ] appreciate it um you can sign
up you get bonus episodes at ayg you get
episodes of hard feelings
which is me and uh foley behind the
curtains a little bit [ __ ] on each
other did a little comic bashing this
week oh yeah
that one that one can't get released
talking a little [ __ ] and then every
month we do a live stream
uh with our top tier patrons where we
ask you questions you ask us questions
it's a good [ __ ] time
yes it is and have a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man he makes us
all look good give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes hey
everybody
[ __ ] you guys look like such [ __ ]
next to this guy
holy [ __ ] you have never looked pastier
i know
i don't know if that bothers you or not
but i
you look at me like i'm a pile of trash
me oh i do too i certainly do
ladies and gentlemen you know him from
oops to podcast he's a previous guest
it's a
it's a it's a little company in the
house here um you got to go check out
his episode it's absolutely amazing
you got to check out oops to podcast and
you got to check him out on patreon
he's got his own patreon he's producing
his own patreon he's got a smash hit on
there called arthelene
alternate side parking thursday my
favorite thing on instagram it's
fantastic it's him just [ __ ] dealing
with the parking nightmare that is new
york city
give it up for the one the only francis
allison
hey thank you so much for having me back
fellas buddy thanks for coming i mean
you can't not comment on it like
what are you doing to your skin are you
are you doing anything
or is this just genetics here's the
thing listen you're a great comic funny
guy
absolutely fantastic i don't mean to
just point at your physical features no
but they are alarming i feel like you
got better since the last time we had
you on the podcast
well he's definitely gotten worse could
be that juxtaposition
my eyes have gotten fatter uh
i i i've been a redhead my whole life
so i've had to protect my skin but it's
strawberry
that's really the answer dude people ask
people do ask me like what's your
skincare routine
it's sunscreen and i'm not even being
funny about that like i start my day
with a with a moisturizer that has 20
spf in it
right and uh i think i think sun is the
number one thing that makes people look
old it makes you look like a catcher's
mitt real quick
you look like us i could have been him
yeah well i got
i mean i started hold on no you could
that was the joke
um i started because once we started in
hd
i we've just been i've been getting
[ __ ] destroyed so i've been doing a
face care routine myself trying to bring
back a little bit of the life or stop it
what is what's in your routine i'm
curious i got well we went out i went to
this fancy spa
and we spent a couple hundred bucks on
some products well it was i got a facial
i was there and then i bought the
products they used okay
um yeah all organic and [ __ ] so it's
like a class is that a bowl
what is that it's just a face mask uh
yeah so it's pretty good uh
i love it you know uh i i think having
some kind of a routine is
i hate i hate that word like what's your
skincare routine
let me ask you this so we're they're
they're busting my chops that i'm a
little heavy that i got to lose some
weight
i just out of curiosity you're a classy
guy i would like to know what is your
daily routine like as far as like
working out getting up what do you eat
for breakfast
what do you do the loofah what are you
doing i like to eat
um you get overnight oats in the morning
it's classy i think he's
not classy no that's nice you're
pre-meditated that's
overnight oats well it's you could you
could also just do oatmeal
instant oatmeal sure what do you put in
it is it soy milk or is it regular milk
oat milk bro
really yeah watch out for that oatley i
think they just ipo'd actually and how
how much are we talking about the first
guest to ever address an ipo
[Laughter]
i don't even know what that means but it
sounds cool it's where they went public
and so you can buy their stuff
yeah but dude i'm telling you if you
like oat milk
uh there's only one brand and then if
you if they don't have it
at the supermarket and you have to buy
any of those other brands
garbage yeah yeah absolutely oh i know
oatley's the one oatley is the one and i
don't want to like give free ads or
anything like that but
i'm telling you if you've ever our
listeners are not buying oatmeal if
you've ever been
you know you know how you know it's
garbage because the other brands aren't
even allowed to call it oat milk they
call it oat beverage
you're drinking oat beverage step your
[ __ ] game you're garbage
yeah yeah um so wait hold on i want to
hear this so you get up in the morning
what's the first thing you do
uh i do the crossword the new york times
crossword puzzle on my phone
what yeah honestly
what time do you get up in the morning
oh like seven 7 30.
no matter what time you go to bed you
get up at seven o'clock
yeah i can't really sleep i'm not a very
good sleeper any anymore and you do the
new york times in bed
yeah my girlfriend brings me a coffee
it's it's part of our uh
exchange of goods for services all right
i kind of like that i like where this is
going
well she's got her chores i got my
chores her bringing me a coffee
what are you wearing that time of day
just out of curiosity just for the
listeners
so you're in bed you do the new york
times crossroad puzzle how long does
that take yeah
uh 20 minutes 20 minutes yeah just about
take me two weeks now you can't even
afford the face once you start doing it
you get the
mon like early days of the week they're
much easier monday tuesday wednesday's
easier thursday friday it's really hard
yeah i can't finish it off really
same friday yeah so okay so you do that
then start on a monday
uh get up take a shower uh you know then
i put my my spf on uh-huh
moisturizer with the built-in spf and
then i uh
get to get to emails and and writing and
all that stuff
and then around uh 5 p.m i usually do my
exercising that's what you do then you
work out yeah then shower again
yep and then off to spots or whatever
that's it yeah and what what are you
having for lunch so
when do you have the oat milk or the the
oats that's uh
usually around like 8 30 9. okay and
it's just a small portion i would assume
i probably i don't even know what you'd
call i eat a lot dude i eat a little
yeah huh people are always um kind of
aghast
you're a big guy you burn a lot of
calories yeah i mean i eat healthy food
but i eat
a lot of it sort of the quantities that
what's the last thing you had today
let's let's start there
uh i i didn't have much time today so i
had just a bunch of pre-made
chicken salad that i bought at like
whole foods
okay and then i had half an avocado no
bread it's a tight shape
do you eat a lot of bread it probably
doesn't touch this stuff what are you
talking about what about fast food
no even wendy's she's a nice girl
i like i like wendy's but the problem is
uh
when i eat it i get i feel like awful
it's just my body
[ __ ] rejects it yeah and then i know
that
i fight through it i fight through it
like [ __ ]
you take it personally not this time
wendy
my fully starts his day his girl brings
him a honey baked ham
[Laughter]
i do some mad libs
i hit the coloring book for about 20
minutes connect the dots
oh it's a it's a constellation i can't
finish the word fine on fridays
this goddamn marmaduke it's up to
trouble i'll tell you that
what this kid's doing
oh my god well he's asking we just we're
doing a weight loss challenge for him
this month he's a classy guy
i like to learn that's what i'm saying
came and we asked if he wanted to water
he's like no i brought my own i knew it
was going to be a [ __ ]
reusable water bottle yeah very he's the
reason i like this
is because it's bigger than those yes
and i need more water
that's not enough water for me i know
i'll do a couple of these it's like 38
ounces
how many of those do you drink a day
like two at least yeah yeah
gotta stay hydrated yeah what about a
hair product what do you put in there
i don't have i don't i'm not a big hair
product guy and there's a reason
really yeah it's because i i sweat and
then it drips into my eyes and my eyes
stink yeah
i i find that that problem too i don't
like having the
hair gel sweat in my eyeballs what about
your shampoo and stuff like that
and she's head and shoulders two for one
real you're doing twofers
well yeah it's it then i don't have to
do both the conditioner and
what about the soap you gotta have
something
well i do use for the soap i use the dr
bronner's
yeah it leaves your skin all tingly does
use the mint and if you're out camping
and you're in a pinch you can use it for
everything yeah
wash your clothes with it you can brush
your teeth with it shampoo
soap yeah man they a little goes a long
way doctor
is all right i love that tingle on the
nuts
[Laughter]
soon to be illegal by the way well thank
you i wanted to know
that's my routine did you have braces
yeah i did
flawless teeth for 11 months i hated him
11 months it was a short time jesus i
told him i didn't want him anymore i had
him for like four years yeah my sister
was six
on your legs all right come on you're
lobbing these up
oh man good stuff we appreciate
also i want to say the [ __ ] alternate
side parking
hysterical is so funny thank you so good
it's developed we were talking about it
the other night before we even hit you
up to do the pod we were talking about
how funny it was
and you've created this world on your
block
there's the cow there's recurring
characters yeah
you call it the fast and the furious car
or whatever yeah there's a bad max fury
road car
he's never there gets a ticket every
week doesn't seem to care i mean it's
not a bad way to go because the tickets
are 65 dollars
sometimes i roll the dice yeah and and
he's just willing to collect one every
week that's roughly whatever 270 dollars
about a parking spot is it's less than a
parking garage
yeah so he just doesn't deal with it he
pays his tickets or doesn't who knows
and uh that's when you get in trouble
they can come and get you that's he
could get booted
i've been voted have you been booted how
long does it take
for you to get booted how many tickets
do you need to get here's the deal
i can i know it 100 as yeah so here's so
here's the story you have
you get a ticket you have one month to
pay that ticket
after that one month it monetarily
increases a little bit
if you get to the point where it's over
350 dollars and it's been a month
that's when they can boot you really 350
in fines
yes fines then they come and boot you
all right so you got the 350
you're sitting there then they come and
boot you they tack
[Laughter]
he's got to keep a ledger come on keep
my man's right if you got you got 40 you
got 400. now you're looking at like 789
dollars
to remove the boots it's a remote it's
like i think i paid 880 to get my here's
the thing
you gotta have you got to have all the
your your documents in order too
oh my gosh which i don't know if you
know that about us our documents tend to
not be
our affairs aren't always in order
here's the thing too is
so let's say it's a thursday morning
you go downstairs [ __ ] i got a boot you
have
between an hour and 24 hours
to get your [ __ ] straight because you
got the [ __ ] tow truck coming around
you're now on the list so whenever
[ __ ] bozo joe in the tow truck
comes around and you don't have your
ship then they're taking it
now you got [ __ ] 788 now we're
probably tacking on [ __ ] two
300 for [ __ ] storage fees when they
tell you yeah
i don't i don't mean to dude i don't
mean to get blue on this
wonderful show but one of my favorite
pornos
is bad tow truck driver really
yeah is that was that like a genre or a
specific it's a
website
cars and they're like is there anything
i can do and then
get in the tow truck and there's
something very kind of
i don't know mechanical about it that i
enjoy
right in my wheelhouse i'll pay 880 for
that girls do not want to get towed
they too i gotta get the water i haven't
seen that but i'm big into snowplow porn
okay all right little liam neeson vibe i
like a couple of snow bunnies
well i couldn't get away with that with
this tow truck driver he was playing
hardball i had some i had to call my mom
and get the credit card number
quick yeah i remember that was one of
the funniest things ever he called her
and she's like well what are you gonna
do when he goes i'm doing it
i'm calling you get the credit get the
credit card he's like i'm not calling
you to brainstorm
you're playing stupid honey go get the
visa
um but so then when you tell it when
they boot it
um i found out i got booted because i
went to work i left it i had it
and then my buddy who lives in the
neighborhood took a picture of it and
sent me my car booted which is a tough
that is a tough tip picture to get um
but you can take it off yourself there's
a combo number on it where they go
oh the code is one one two four seven
sure and then you take it off and you
have up to 48 hours to return it or they
charge you for the booth for the boots
or they'll come take it off but they'll
be like it'll take up to two hours yeah
so if you have somewhere to go you can
take it off right away and leave but
then you have to go return the boot and
the only place i could return it was in
the bronx
and was that like a regular gas station
oh my god he just accepts it and i was
like
so embarrassed i'm like i gotta walk in
here and stand in line
with people paying for gas with a boot
to be like i'm
holding it for a friend or whatever
there's no way to not look like a
[ __ ] jerk it's my cousin's he's
you're out of town
and then i remembered i was in the bronx
and like the guy in front of me was like
already drinking a bud ice
like that he was paying for he started
drinking before he paid for it i'm like
oh i'll be all right yeah
they walked in i'm like i'm returning
this they're like yeah whatever man here
go i love
that yeah you've never you have you do
you get tickets or no
i've gotten tickets but i've never been
booted because i i pay them pretty quick
yeah because i'm in the game so i can't
risk
getting booted yeah i make sure i pay
them within a month too i'm usually
carrying about one or two wow usually
yeah
interesting because what they switched
the alternate side parking a little bit
to not two days a week now one day a
week that's that's why
part of the reason why the spots are so
coveted now yes
because what what typically happens is
normally in normal times
there are you know tuesdays and
thursdays let's say or wednesdays and
fridays 100
the street sweeper comes from 9 to 10
30.
people uh you know instead of
playing what i call the alternate side
parking the waiting game yeah which is
where you sit in your car uh
because it's two days a week like people
can't afford that so they just
they relocate switch to a different
street or whatever yeah
there's kind of like a musical chairs of
parking spots
uh but now given that it's one day a
week most people
can find a way to you know get out of
work for just an hour and a half or do
their work in their car for that time
and they go do it and it was that's what
led to this whole series developing
well i say this as i say this as a
driver in new york a dirt bag all right
i'm a dirtbag i'm lazy i don't want to
[ __ ] move the car
it's my street is so [ __ ] dirty
because they're doing it only one day a
week now yeah there's nails
everywhere well it's that and it's also
there
the city does not do they suspend
alternate side parking
if there is the faintest hint
of a religious holiday oh yeah any
denomination
any crazy sect of anything that
celebrates that day they honor it and
they say no no alter inside barking
which i'm surprised de blasio did that
because that
that shit's a [ __ ] money maker for
the city it is
it is and it's also surprising that they
uh
went to one day a week in covid because
you're right
well it was nothing covet for a while
yeah it was zero
but if they if they have it two days a
week they issue more tickets
sure make more money you know they pay
their
drivers in the department of sanitation
and all of that i've become friends with
those guys i know i saw which is the
coolest thing people sweet pizza sweetie
you're friends with the street sweeper
it's hilarious it's the funniest [ __ ]
thing
he did he did my first like live happy
hour on the patreon and we just had gear
sweep on the patreon talk for an hour it
was awesome
so [ __ ] funny i have a bargain
question so in in chicago when it snows
you shovel out your spot
dibs is that a thing in new york no no
people
have talked about that though in chicago
they honor billy's the same thing
you see you see like someone's chair or
trap trampoline
or whatever it is if you move the chair
people will slash your tires yeah and
everyone around them will be like yeah
that's what you get yeah
yeah i dig that i think there is
you know whenever you find these
unwritten codes of uh
you know parking decency whatever it is
in different cities i find that very
authentic and and then you but you and
like anywhere i'm sure you get violators
right yeah people who don't play by the
game that's that is what happens in new
york which leads to fights
well new york we have the one which i
strongly i'm i'm totally okay with this
if you drive by a parking spot and
somebody's standing in the spot saying
he's circling the block he's going to be
here in a minute you let them have the
spot
you do you don't i don't i haven't
encountered it
but um you know i i i don't like you
about it i don't like it i say it but
it's also like what are you going to do
they're going to run the person over
there you have a choice exactly right i
don't i
i would never do that i would never be
like no someone's coming
yeah it's crazy i feel like that's an
unwritten rule in new york city like the
chair thing
but the snow remember the snow this year
i i got i
dodged a bullet because when that last
big snow storm hit
i was down at my parents so [ __ ]
plowed out [ __ ]
drove up and there were just these
mountains yeah
on the side of the road where you could
tell some [ __ ] guy
dug his car out for like [ __ ] three
hours and then had to move it i'm just
snuck right in nice nice clean living
yeah you gotta go over a little snow
embankment yeah you do i got the four
wheel drive what i mean
nice classy four-wheel drive's not too
shabby
what kind of whip do you drive can i ask
you that yeah so
we we took over my girlfriend's
parents lease okay i like it yeah they
kind of give us a good rate it's a nice
car
it's a bmw yeah i love it suv
no just uh the five series nice yeah but
it's great
kids driving around in a bmw classy
kid's class i told you shop at whole
foods exclusively
uh or or trader joe's yeah whatever
whatever
trader joe's is cheap as hell i know
trader joe's is cheaper than any of
those diagostinos oh yeah
new york grocery store there's a new one
that just opened
in my neighborhood it's called little
right or am i saying wrong it's that
german needle yeah
lid it looks weird everything looks the
same
let me tell you something this place
they tiptoe around copyright
infringement like
it's nobody's business because it looks
exactly the same
they had frosted flakes and it was some
snowman
i swear to god it was a box of frosted
flakes and instead of tony the dagger it
was a snowman
yeah trader joe's does that too you know
sneaky
instead of hunting out cheerios it'll be
like honey nut
uh you know trader joey and you're like
give me a [ __ ] break
you know i can't do that i can't do the
generic stuff
no no i can't do it i need the games on
the back
yeah i had first of all like all growing
up and they [ __ ] sucked
that's probably what foley does in bed
in the morning playing the word
search on the back of a cereal box i
found the second toucan
what's different between these two
pictures hey captain crunch really gets
himself in a pickle you know what i mean
you can't you're stuck in the maze you
can't get out
gang let's face it we all shop online
these days no one's going to the store
like a bozo like a doofus and don't you
hate that when you get to the promo code
section when you're about to check out
and you're staring at it and you got
nothing zip nada and you're paying full
price
like a bazzo well our friends at honey
are going to change all that
honey supports over 3 000 stores online
they range from
they range from sites that have gaming
products to popular fashion brand i got
it all
even food delivery and what they do is
instead of manually searching for promo
codes
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds
to your cart yeah guys uh
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites and when you go to check
out the honey button drops down and all
you have to do is click
apply coupon hold that honey button
you're not sitting there
clipping you know the sunday newspapers
looking for coupons it does it for you
baby
you wait a few seconds honey searches
all over the internet finds out what it
can do and lowers the price for you
when we were putting puddy's studio
together i mean me and t-bone were
making a thousand purchases a day
all on honey wetting our beaks on the
lights the cameras the action baby
whatever you need
we got it so give it a shot um
so if you don't already have honey uh
you're just straight up missing out on
savings that's what you're doing it's
literally free and installs on your
on your browser in a few seconds and by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
and supporting
this podcast yes if you like us this is
an easy way
to support us i never i never i would
never recommend something i don't use
or my wife uses it for shopping for
clothes it's easy peasy
you get honey for free at joinhoney.com
garbage one more time baby that's
joinhoney.com
garbage did you just give them the kippy
guarantee
my name's on and i guarantee check out
honey gang let's take a quick second to
talk about one of our favorite sponsors
who's that
our biggest supporters here on the show
of course i'm talking about
the good people at fume oh yeah all
right
fume is a natural inhaler that makes it
easy to get the benefits
of super plants on the go here's how it
works it's simple
fume is a canadian made wood inhaler
with no electronics
it has cores filled only with the
benefits of super plants
no chemicals at it they're absolutely
fantastic
it's a natural portable tool for algae
relief relaxation
and a great nicotine replacement tool
that fits right
in your pocket i'm telling you guys they
sent us a whole bunch of the stuff
three of us have tried it out been using
it it helps if you're on the bernie's
it's a good
substitute for smoking bernie's if
you're smoking cigs
smoking sticks forever ain't if there's
no future in that you know what i mean
you got to cut them at some point
gotta kick the habit and fume can help
they sent us one uh for allergy relief
that i've been using because my
[ __ ] face has been wanting to punch
myself in the forehead all day it's
horrible
how your allergies no good bad dish here
it's horrible your car's covered in
pollen a couple hits of [ __ ] fume
you're feeling a-okay you know what i
mean um so check out the variety of
blends and their benefits at
breathefume.com
that's b-r-e-a-t-h-e fume
f-u-m and use promo code garbage for 10
off on your order today one more time
baby write it down
put it in your phone in your notes open
the browser breathfume.com
promo code garbage for 10 off your order
today
gang we got a little company we're
reading your questions here
kevin ryan hey gang um we gotta we got
some good ones
uh let's see this let's oh before we get
into that i had a couple car ones can i
ask that since we're on the on the card
thing sure
um did you ever i guess
this kind of goes with the with the
lease but did you ever sell a car if
did your family ever sell a car to
somebody that you know
and then you see that car driving around
all the time
no no or dealership family i i i had
that happen
really and dude the guy paid us in cash
oh i like that and and uh
and and i think are we talking like five
grand are we talking like 15
no it was like four thousand whose car
was we had bought it my sister
it was the car my sister and i split it
was like a 1993
volvo you know that i mean
it it it almost coal
[ __ ] that came out of the exhaust every
trip to school was
one polar bear's life
at least and killed him two seals a week
yeah
and we ended up selling it to
uh this this kid we knew his dad came to
buy it his dad
uh did landscaping for a living so
clearly just got paid
in cash yeah and he showed up with like
a a
gangster roll of 20s which we then put
in like a soup jar and then i kind of
whittled down over
you know yeah now how did you how did
you advertise the car
was it out front on the lawn or was it
like did you do that or did you drive
around with the for sale sign
the or best offer that's a great
question i don't exactly know maybe
i don't even know how they found out
they might have been in like the yellow
pages or something okay
crazy i feel that's the way to do it
yeah like that's a tough one seeing your
car driving around town
yeah i wouldn't like that yeah so you
would see that car like school and [ __ ]
yeah but the kid had he was super into
like auto repair and i think he replaced
a bunch of the parts and that's kind of
like
nicer than what we had had as it and
souped it up
yeah uh what about you ever try to win
the car at the mall you ever do that
um i've tried to win i think i've tried
to win the car at the airport
i think i didn't even know they gave him
away at the airport maybe it might not
be but you were just robbing cars in
long-term parking
i signed up once for some kind of thing
at the airport that was big as a kid and
i'd be like they're just giving this
away if you put your name in
it's crazy i don't i still don't
understand how that works and this is
the most two things send murderous rages
up my spines
especially in new york the [ __ ] who
put those things in the back of their
mufflers
that go i'm talking about yeah
i guess yeah and the muffler and the
train horn the [ __ ] who puts the
[ __ ]
horn uh yeah i want to [ __ ] see oh i
want to get a
one of those big pellegrino bottles and
throw it right through their [ __ ]
window nice
drives me insane that's a classy way to
message
heavens to betsy and i was sparkling
you're looking at the still on me
you know a brickle worked too no the
last question car related would be
do you think it's trashy to lean on
somebody's car that isn't yours
that's the first part we just did that
the other day
or is it trashy to yell at somebody for
leaning on your car
oh what if you walked up to alternate
side parking and somebody was
leaning on on the beam i had like a cup
of coffee
no no coffee on it i'll do that i i hate
to say this i think a lot of it would
depend on on who was leaning on the car
sure you know if it's some some twerp
some guy who's like
coming back from a run and he's
stretching his hamstrings by using the
car
to balance you know he's doing his quads
or whatever and he's just
kind of using it as a balance yeah a
beam or whatever
give that a pass i think i'd let that
guy go okay yeah good for him what if
he's sitting on the hood
yeah if there's some guy what if it's me
leaning up like
sitting on the hood i'm gonna be like
listen you can have the car
you clearly have more confidence than i
ever coming back
i don't think i can sit in it anymore
that happened one night we were drunk
and we were somewhere and got like a
bunch of like pizza and wings and we
were all [ __ ] we just like put it on
some of the hood of someone's car
philly [ __ ] dish i know we were just
so drunk like you know i'm not saying it
was right
and we were just like treat it was like
thanksgiving dinner dude like chicken
and then this guy walked up he's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing i'm like i'm
sorry sir
just like dude i [ __ ] bitched up real
quick
did you think a chicken tenders here
yeah real real quick
all right i'm sorry i just figured i
wanted to get the car questions out
let's go we have another one this one's
for all right so this is uh guys as you
know when you sign up for the patreon we
will answer your garbage question on
air it's just the best way to do it um
because we get we get a [ __ ] ton of
submissions
um so this one's from sam and it is car
related
have you ever taken a drink from home in
an open glass or a mug
in the car um yes like with like a prop
wow really coffee yeah in a mug no lid
oh sure i can see him i like to i like
to have a nice
iced coffee you know okay and uh i'll
i'll bring it in a mason jar with ice
wow yeah i don't know what to feel about
that yeah
does he get spills or is that just when
you're sitting in an alternate side
uh i take it with me to go do alternate
side and um
i i don't like lids in general
and i'll tell you i'll tell you why
there's something to me about
um getting the sip straight from
the big sip is nice yeah and and you get
you get
um i don't know you i feel like i'm i'm
more connected to the drink i'm getting
it the way it was supposed to be
i'm just wait god intended i don't know
why but i totally agree with you yeah
i'm not a big strong guy yes
yeah i'm over the straw not a straw guy
yeah like a nice sip
and i think what he's saying is classy
especially the mason jars
reusable it's not a [ __ ] plastic cup
or anything like that he's bringing it
from his home i know do you make the
iced coffee in your house
yeah you make it you cold brew it so
or is it just hot coffee yeah we have
like a an espresso thing
and what we'll do is i'll do like two
shots of espresso
and then oat milk with a bunch of ice in
it and that's my drink that's my coffee
drink every day
do you have a reusable straw that you
use no
i don't i just don't i don't i don't do
straws in any way shape or form
a lid for a stroke i don't like a lid
yeah that's fair play yeah
yeah do you have an ice machine in your
freezer yeah
you do not one that you go like that no
no not on the door it's a big
bin that refills like a chicken coop
i gotta tell you when you have people
over right and then you get
through all that ice and you're like
shoot we're out of ice and then you wait
an hour and you go back in
and the machine has laid seven new ice
cubes
you feel great you're like thank you for
the bounty
deer chicken freezer we're living off
the earth have you guys ever have you
guys ever collected eggs from a chicken
coop
no my cousin my cousin baseball cards
what even
displayed them like collected them like
that
oh my god this guy is out to lunch
i thought you meant like you had an egg
i got an 83 rooster over here come check
it out
have you ever fetched eggs now have you
ever gone to
now i went to a self-sustaining farm one
time with my brother and his family
and we had eggs that were from that farm
and they were [ __ ]
lights out yeah they were like they were
glowing orange
i'm troubled that your mind though went
to somebody whose hobby it was
i said to to hold for value absolutely
is probably a synonym for that what's a
cinnamon oh synonym okay
yeah cinnamon i like cinnamon all my
eggs
yeah i usually just do salt and pepper
i'll give it if you say it's cool i'll
do
it hold on uh
you go and you get the eggs from from
the chickens
yeah in the morning i don't know i i
grew up in maine and they're
a neighborhood yeah a chicken coop and i
gotta tell you
banging going going to get those after
the chickens have
have laid them at night and you go in
there and you see fresh eggs it's
like finding diamonds yeah so you don't
need to they don't need to ferment or
anything like that you don't have to
treat them or anything
nothing you can really just straight out
yeah and they weren't going home
crack them in a pan eat your omelet and
they weren't gonna those
chickens weren't gonna use those eggs
anyway they're like just they're no they
don't eat eggs
be weird
no but how does how does the egg become
a chicken you have to incubate it
oh right that's true so it's a good
question
and i don't actually know the answer to
this but i i do think right so those
chickens
it's possible that they expect to sit on
them
and grow them into no because doesn't
the male sit on them or is that ducks
that's penguins i think that might be
some of those arctic animals
yeah yeah uh guys this might blow your
mind
but there has to be some jizz involved
so yeah they're right that's right
it comes it's if it if it comes out as
an egg
that you can eat it was never going to
be that's what i thought okay so there
are
it's not like fish where they squirt the
eggs out and they jizz on top of the
eggs and then they become
chickens okay but let me ask you
it's insane that you're my bosses
don't forget at the end of the month all
right we got a chicken guy over here so
[Laughter]
i got questions yeah that was the best
insult or whatever
we got a chicken guy over here real
ladies man huh you're talking real tough
for a guy wearing his own merch
it was free i figured i'd show you how
dare you talk to mr alice like that
i felt bad the second i did it he's so
nice but
i didn't mean chicken guy as an insult
either i meant no i know somebody who
knows about this for the record i
i enjoyed it as an insult
it was sharp i have a follow-up question
if you said that to me i would have
changed high schools i would if you hit
me with that in the cafeteria i would
have moved
if if there are chickens uh that
those chicken the eggs that we're
talking about where you would just eat
them that have not been
fertilized by sperm uh how would those
eggs
would those eggs if some if a male
chicken fertilize them
become uh new chickens
no i don't think they can fertilize them
post yeah it's got to be done
no i'm reading it right now for eggs to
be fertilized the hen and the rooster
must mate first and the process occur
this and this process must occur prior
to the formation of the egg
thus if the hen has made it and lays an
egg
then that egg is fertilized in this
process hold the egg up to the
candlelight to see if you can point out
the blood spots in the embryo
yeah so basically like like i throw
those ones out the eggs from chickens
that we eat is like the chicken's period
it's like them
shedding they're unfertilized gotcha
gotcha
interesting that's and and and yet if
there were a rooster running around that
coop
all of those eggs would become new
chicks
before they had they laid the egg so
that was my question i didn't know if
there were
because i know that there are chickens
that are grown for meat and then there
are chickens that are grown
for laying eggs and they're two
different types of chickens i didn't
know i didn't know that
i'm pretty sure where were you on that
one chicken man yeah
should we have a chicken off guess you
weren't in the coop that day huh oh god
this thing went off the rails
are you a quail egg guy no hit them hit
the bricks with yours you're not allowed
yeah no way those things they've been
pushing those on people
yeah um my cousin went all
he built a [ __ ] chicken coop what
just does his own he's got like where
does he live
out like the main line by like villanova
no [ __ ] they're just like
i think they're in the shed or something
he's just got a [ __ ] coop and he just
does fresh eggs all the time it's cool
it's
it's like i was buying all these [ __ ]
eggs and i wanted to go farm to table
and i just was like oh [ __ ] it we got
this
it's like next to the go-kart it is you
know in the in the same way of like
people who grow their own weed i i think
having your own chicken coop
so you can eat fresh eggs from your
backyard every morning is one of the
most like
satisfying things you could have if i
had to land i would get in on it
we got something to do we got foxes down
where my parents are we couldn't do it
they come in again there was a peter
paul and mary song about that
really yeah about the foxes getting into
the chicken coop
ever you guys know peter paul and mary
no the folk singers that
sang for children hey listen thanks for
coming in
no i don't is it like from when we were
kids
yeah wait i know peter paul and mary
come on foley there you go what are they
saying puff the magic dragon yeah they
they did puff the magic dragon yeah me
too
they're having fun here um how do you
start talking about eggs
i don't know i don't know
oh you asked if i ever collected eggs i
don't even know why i asked that though
i don't know but it got a great answer
and thinking there was egg collectors
have you ever collected anything like
baseball cards or anything like that in
your life yeah i i did uh i did
basketball cards i was really into
basketball cards and i'll tell you this
in light of the recent boom in
collectibles i went back to my my
childhood home and looked through my
basketball card collection and then
crawford cross-referenced to see if i
had anything that was worth anything and
i actually added up the
rough value of all my cr cards i thought
it would be like a few thousand dollars
it was like
28 dollars i did the same thing i have
like
i have like 30 michael jordan cards and
no
not a single one of them was like had a
crude value they weren't rare
32 cents yeah they're nothing they just
made too many of them it made me bummed
me out dude i thought i was sitting on a
gold mine
yeah when i was in i probably like
junior or sophomore year baseball cards
got really hot so this is probably like
92
93 it got really really hot and i
thought we had [ __ ] we had the whole
tops collection
from like 81 to whatever there's [ __ ]
4 billion of them out there
yeah yeah you got to get one more like
somebody's upside down or something like
that
you need the holograms and the
autographs and the game worn jersey
cards
those are the ones yeah i could never
get into that [ __ ] yeah have you ever
gotten an autograph off anybody
i was a huge autographed hound really
well i had this lucky thing happen where
when i was in sixth grade i had a really
bad
staph infection that uh sort of seeped
into my ankle joint
became a very septic ankle joint okay so
it's blood poisoning yeah and uh you
know that's when it gets dangerous when
it's in your body because you get stop
infections on your skin it's no big deal
but if you get them in your bloodstream
it can kill you where'd you get it from
we don't even know
just an open cut somehow the the
bacteria got in there and then it it
found a home in my ankle joint so it was
really bad i i was in the hospital for
two months i had
one of those ivs in my heart like the
tube the catheter
damn so that they could just pump
gallons of antibiotics right into my
heart
really yeah it was crazy mainline two
months in the hospital yeah i missed
all school everything lost like 20
pounds as a seventh
sixth graders do that there you go
that'll work what can i get a staph
infection around here
but you come out of that and and uh my
dad as a way of trying to perk me up
because i was pretty down in the dumps
uh we got a 10 game package to the
boston celtics
nice and we would drive down to boston
from maine
and uh we would get there really early
so i could go hunt for autographs
and i'm going down to the floor and
waiting for the guys to come out after
doing their shoot around
warm up and i'm i'm this sickly kid
they'd let you down on the floor no not
like on the floor but you know right
right next barry all right you're a
little kid yeah and i'm i'm sickly and
i've got this tube in my chest
there's like i have no color i've got
braces and i just
i was the make-a-wish kid basically
that's awesome and you just i mean you
rake in
yeah the autographs i think i had a
lebron autograph i
i had a you know a bunch of eric snow
shout out to e snow baby that's crazy
yeah best point guard on the biz
a bunch of the celtics so i had those
but those were not on cards those were
on like
a piece of paper or whatever it was like
uh the the when you get the thing at the
game what the hell is that program
program there you go
very nice yeah yeah i like it
i've never really collected much um
never had the patience for it
this one i don't even understand this is
from remy is it trash leave a gift card
as a tip
yeah what do you mean you don't
understand that i mean i don't
understand people doing that
that's nuts like what are you leaving
like a marshall's gift card or something
garbage that's actually
rash i love how he sees how the poor
people operate
also by the way on the one challenge on
patreon it was you had the funniest
comment
because it was he's never been in a limo
so i was like oh we're taking foley
foley's never been in a limo and then i
said in parentheses even for a funeral
and you were like i love how that's an
acceptable time to be in a liberty
yeah i was thinking prom right it would
be the number one like
somebody's got to go foley house
who was [ __ ] on me for this my prom
i drove my own car
yeah i think it was me you and reggie
were [ __ ] on you would you take to
the prom
oh you did a did a big stretch limo with
like 12 kids
okay split it everyone pays like 30
bucks yeah yeah yeah that's the way to
do it yeah so we're dylan it's like a
white nissan maxima
quit bragging that the state police were
combing through several hours later
why because a couple of a couple of our
our boys had a couple of cocktails
before they got in the car i didn't
i took acid like a gentleman
and there ain't no state trooper tests
or that acid to go to prom
yeah you must have been a great date
yeah that was fun i wonder why he
couldn't afford a limo
[ __ ] deadbeat at 18. goddamn
i don't understand who would ever leave
a gift like a visa gift card or like uh
i don't know i think that's acceptable
but if you leave like a cracker barrel
gift card if you're at like the olive
gardener yeah no
that's trashy because you there's just
the trust issue there
because if you have just a gift card you
also can't pay your rent with a gift
card if it's
limited if it's yeah if it's unopened
maybe
no but you don't know what's left on
there if somebody said hey here's a gift
card
there's 15 left on there that's your tip
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's like people even change i also
think that that gift cards just carry
with them a general understanding that
these are being re-gifted
so often yes you know i got this i'm not
gonna use it
congratulations go go buy a notebook at
staples yeah
gift card in general is just a horrific
gift yeah yeah give me the cash
like why why make me buy something that
you know [ __ ] dick's sporting goods
or something and i don't know me well
enough
to specify the one place i can shop yes
exactly yes i give my sister-in-law a
gift card every once in a while but
she's
victoria's secret
[Laughter]
hey spice things up up there will you
[Laughter]
um no she like loves home goods like
loves home goods
so i'll get like a hundred dollar gift
card to home goods stop that
i don't think she likes that she's
saying she likes it she's like what more
do i need from [ __ ] home goods
all right now you're giving them a chore
to go to homegoods and this is the other
problem
with the gift card is that she goes to
home goods and she either feels
constrained by the
amount you've given her or she's like
okay well i'll put
75 bucks towards this thing comes out to
150.
she's still spending 75 of her own value
it doesn't feel that good sure you're
right
yeah you know you're they're going hey
yeah to try to find the exact thing for
if the card's 100 bucks find something
for 99
or you know it's like then now she's
buying [ __ ] that she doesn't need lose
the gift cards everybody lose the
[ __ ] gift i'm with you
you're right yeah i apologize um this
isn't the same kind of vein this is from
t
mackin uh what is the smallest amount of
money you'll pick up off the street
oh great question yeah i was thinking
about this the other day
two dollars has started to feel
like a decent amount of money again why
so
um i think i think because i i
left my job okay and lost my salary
and i started to think about it and i
was like man
two dollars is an amount that i can't
ignore anymore
really what about a dollar on the ground
a dollar
on the ground if i were to pick it up i
would probably
give it to a homeless person wow that's
a that's a
really that's a classy you're picking up
dirty money off the ground then you
gotta look for a homeless guy well you
know you give it a glance and see if
it's that
you know poop money trick or if it's on
a fishing line or something yeah exactly
i'll get you that you look around these
damn kids yeah fool me once
i pick up pennies do you really it's got
to be a p
yeah but it's it's an ocd thing it's got
to be a penny on heads i pick it up i
look at the date
i think about the date like what year it
was then i put it in a separate pocket
that's not that doesn't have other
change in it what do you do
after that i feel like i have good luck
okay
well it's not working interesting i
never
i never pick up money off the street
what's the most money you've ever found
on the ground
120 bucks i was a kid
and we were on the wildwood boardwalk
you [ __ ] scumbag that's just a
robbery
this poor old lady never saw me coming i
found two grand in a ladies dresser one
time
just walking by minding my own business
jesus christ man yeah no it was 120
bucks in a purse all 20s
and did your mom make you give it back
it was with my dad and my stepmom so
rules were a little looser
we weren't always playing on the honors
hey we can go jet skiing no i'm kidding
uh we took it to like the wildwood
like police thing on the boardwalk and
they were like hey
if no one claims this by the end of the
night
like in the lost and found you can come
back and collect it and i was like
dude come like 10 30 i'm like let's go
wrap it up we got to go back to pick up
my [ __ ]
pick up my my goods you know somebody
get it my dad was like we are not going
back to pick up that woman's money good
good it's like we don't he's like we
have money but i don't like i'll give
you 120 bucks
shout out to mr ryan i like it [ __ ]
classy move right there
what about you i found a 50 bill
floating in the pool at club med in the
bahamas when i was a kid you keep it
oh yeah yeah i had my goggles on
under there looking for looking at butt
cheeks yeah you did what were your
parents into they took you to club med
when you were a kid
buddy that that was not as i got you
labeled down as a classy gentleman yeah
okay
okay
you're right you're right is club med
trashy yes it's not great
really i don't know anything about crews
on land
it's where people go to swing and
[ __ ] dirty [ __ ] in hotel rooms dry
land cruise
yeah but it was great man it's all
buffets and uh
i love it the kids you can go you send
them off to camp all day and
you're going around doing all kinds of
stuff i don't know as a kid it was
perfect yeah it'd probably be pretty fun
actually yeah a bunch of bunch of other
little kids
or in organized groups yeah although
i didn't love that stuff as a kid i
didn't bond well with strangers he
either hit the [ __ ] bricks yeah my
mom would be like oh they're
after like seven years old i'm like yo
no more that organized [ __ ] these
[ __ ] weirdos i didn't like
vacation let me be in a pool yeah doing
a scavenger hunt like an [ __ ]
exactly exactly they i always just i
don't know what it was i didn't like
that
when we were when we go to church i
didn't want to do this sunday school
yeah man stay in the congregation you
know let me be
that's great i like so you didn't did
you have a tight group of friends when
you were a kid
yes but you didn't like any outsiders i
didn't that's right i wanted to select
my own friends i didn't want to be
foisted upon
other friends i didn't want to be you
know co-mingled against my will
i stuck with a couple of kids that look
like me hey buddy
what's your skincare routine
[Laughter]
i collect robin eggs
and squirrel feet oh man of you two is
kids
i wanna that's i would have [ __ ] love
to see that encounter
he just got like barbecue sauce all over
here or something
he would have hated me um this one's
from max first timer anyone in your
family ever wear jeans to a funeral
i can't i think you're family yet now no
way one of my homies did that this past
year oh my god
that's rude off wow i think that a
wedding is [ __ ]
tough i'll feel a funeral is better than
a wedding
what no it's more disrespectful you wear
jeans to a wedding you're a [ __ ] bozo
you wear a jeez too no there's no
because if you if there's a wedding if
there's a funeral there's no
there's no suggested attire when you're
going to a wedding
it suggested a tire on the on the
invitation
that's true i don't know but i would
also say i would also say that like
funerals in general i mean are so
somber and so there's such
there may not be a written suggestion
but
yeah you know the social desire is so
defined
more than a wedding weddings have a
range of things sure funerals it's like
dark suit yeah dark suit something dark
whatever
what about for reviewing if you're doing
the viewing
because i might be guilty of this for
sure now that now they tank tops and
flip-flops
no i think of viewing you get a little
bit you get a little bit more away with
because it's the kind of thing you can
do like slacks in a shirt
yeah yeah because that's for that's for
the for the bozos that you're not really
that close to come pay your respects
when you get done work or something like
that i've i've always not gone to the
viewing
no the funeral no to the viewing i don't
go to the viewing
even family well my family doesn't do
that like are you talking about like
open casket
type visitation yeah yeah we're not
we're not into that
what do they do well there's always that
we most of the people in my family
who've passed away have been
cremated okay uh and there's nothing
there's not there's nothing iron's not
there we don't go up and
study the urn see we
we most we're old school catholics so
mostly it's open
casket but people have been cremated and
there's still a viewing
where the family's in line and you go up
and you and you say your condolences and
you keep it moving grab a lifesaver sit
down
and then they do like a little thing i
always stand at the casket and i'm like
have i been here long enough
okay and then i keep it moving say a
prairie keep it moving yeah i i
yeah we're not we're just i guess we're
not that religious so okay that hasn't
been
but but we've done scattering of the
ashes and people show up
in the family for that that i've never
done yeah never been kind of scattering
that's never seen a movie in tv but it
seems like a good time yeah where'd you
scatter them
uh you know i think one time it was like
in
in a garden at their the house because
my grandfather was
loved the planting the roses this is
getting sad
the scene in big lebowski is one of the
old timers
sprinkles it all over his face
so windy ah that's good [ __ ]
um this this
this has to be a no for for mr uh
francis ellis here ever have any major
family events at a vfw
no yeah you are looking at me yeah i
mean my parents got married
i was there of course have you ever been
to a vfw no no
yeah can i be honest you don't know i
don't even know what it is is it a
veteran's decision veterans yes
yeah a foreign vfw is veterans of
foreign war and
they have like clubhouses yeah and you
know dirt balls
like us have family parties they're like
halls kind of yeah you can rent them out
i it's i feel like an [ __ ] because i
do have
service members in the family sure but
we've never gone to a vehicle some of
them are regional too some of them are
nice and some of them aren't so nice
like
my buddy's dad was in the army and they
have one down in brigantine
that's pretty classy it's it's it's by
the it's by the water
so you can get a slip you can put the
boat out there that's nice
and it's nice but one's in like the
middle of pennsylvania
i've been to a couple of tough ones yeah
the food's always
dynamite though a couple of steps i know
the way you're on a mashed potato i can
tell you so
so so give me a breakdown of like um
rotary clubs elks lodges all similar
things cfw
is it do you all have to have been is it
all military foreign military
no just vfw is i think the only
requirement
elks vfw and there's one more what not
the american legion
american legion yes they're the only two
elks and the other one
moose lodge and that [ __ ] are all just
like uh dad's trying to get out of the
house social clubs yeah the whole vibe
of vfw is like you watch your friends
die so beers are a dollar yeah yeah
yeah you've been in the [ __ ] here's
what's up here's a discount of chocolate
ice cold as i said we belong to the elks
log
elks lodge in wildwood new jersey and
it's like the membership a year is like
a couple hundred bucks but then you get
in there and it's like dollar drinks
yeah and it's like we'll just go
like animals it's great you order you
order 500 drinks and you have like
i remember the first time i went i
didn't know and i had like i was like
i'll get this around i had like 300
out ready to pay and they were like oh
it's 32 bucks i'm like just ordered
[ __ ] nine shots
three bucks 15 beers i ordered a
whiskey ginger in an american legion and
the guy goes soda's flat and i went oh
can i have a coke he goes all of the
soda is
all right this one's great this is from
jack have you ever watched the lingerie
football league
[Laughter]
is that what do you know what i'm
talking you know yeah i know about that
they hit pretty hard
yeah and they're smoking
i definitely remember when that came out
i was like this is gonna be great when i
watched it yeah i watched the first
quarter i'm like all right i've had
enough
it's it's a little bit misleading to
call it the lingerie football league in
my mind
sure because they're wearing helmets and
shoulder pads
and you think you're going to get this
like wwe
diva kind of thing and these girls are
it's it's really
female rugby yes it's like yeah they're
beating the [ __ ] out of each other
still it's pretty pretty hot though two
highlights
yeah uh all right let's see
uh did your parents ever uh this is from
fisher did your parents ever pick up a
stranger's souvenir cup
off the floor to take it home on the way
out on the way out of the stadium
oh that's good you see one by the trash
like as you're walking out of the aisle
now i can't say we have i don't have
you know conclusive evidence that we
haven't i'm sure we
i've gripped a couple on the way i will
say this
we we would pay up for the souvenir cup
and then we would have that in the
cup cupboard yeah for years forever
forever
until the the lettering had faded off
yes yeah yeah that's that they were
always the best to put like
something right always bigger than like
the traditional glasses yeah
crush it yeah we were we had flyers like
90
whatever it was like 93 plus stanley cup
playoff cups i think we had
until i graduated a disneyland
definitely a disney cup
he had a club med yeah um i always
thought it was trashy remember like for
a while when like uh
like 7-eleven would have like you could
get like the plastic
plastic big gulp yeah and you could you
paid a certain amount and then if you
came back
in with it you got it you got you got
the the refill cheaper
it's like a 50 cent refill or something
bringing back your own cup to [ __ ]
7-0 well
there was the movie theater too where
you'd get uh
you get the extra large popcorn and the
extra large soda and they'd give you a
free refill
sure and i had friends who would sneak
it in the cup to start
go into the movie 20 minutes later
they'd walk out of the movie and go up
and be like i finished it
and get a free every time they went
that's not that bad
i know people and have been to the
movies with people
that have gone into the trash and
grabbed the cup that's bad
and rinsed it off in the bathroom and
they went out and [ __ ]
got themselves a suit how is your mom
doing by the way
patty wouldn't do that first of all
patty foley does not
pay for [ __ ] anything inside of a
movie theater except for the tickets
and sometimes not even that we talked
about this with you we did
the egregious thing he does is he does
meal prep
at home and bring leftovers then take
leftovers oh yeah that's right were you
eating like sushi or chicken or
something
yeah okay broccoli rice
chicken dude that is the act of an
insane person
[Music]
did any of you guys have movie pass when
that was going no
i know what you're talking about that
was people were ripping the movies off
left tonight it was like 10 bucks you
could see
any movie you wanted yeah some [ __ ]
bozo won the lottery
was like i got a business idea yeah and
free movies for everybody
give me ten bucks um all right let's do
a couple more here uh this one's from
mark is it garbage to still wear your
high school class ring
four [ __ ] show yeah yeah did you get
one no
no really no did you get one from
college no i didn't do the
i bought the yearbook from college what
did you go to school again
harvard right i did yeah so you didn't
get a harvard ring i think i would do it
yeah
harvard it was like i don't know it
might have been a thousand bucks or
something
i i don't even know but the yearbook was
like 250
and i just got the yearbook i
respectfully do you sign a yearbook
colleagues
go around to your friends and say hey
have a great summer and [ __ ] like that
i think class rings are cool if you went
to one of the military academies
yes or the citadel or like whatever i
think harvard and yale kind of
get up there too i feel like if you have
a classroom harvard yale you're
definitely cia
what's what's um uh if you went to
clemson everyone from clemson wears
their class ring really
yeah it's like a huge thing bozos
yeah that's a tough look they tried to
sell us hard
of my high school class ring and there
was like one or two guys that got it
and they got it like two days before
graduation and they looked like
idiots walking around with them we i
went to public school i don't even think
that
they had them yeah we had them they
tried for us they like anybody at like
an
assembly they're like who's interested
in the glass ring and everybody started
like doing them like all right
like get the [ __ ] out of here nerds how
was the food at harvard how was the
cafeteria food
it was all right it just got right it
wasn't like
you know they're cooking for too many
people
it's just it's still a cop hospital yeah
you know
and we chicken breasts that are cooked
in water we've had to have ask you this
on your episode
because you mentioned harvard what'd you
get in your sats
uh i forgot what it was i did the one
that had three sections so that's 26.
24. yeah 800 800
and i did like a 2280 or something damn
yeah
smart kid pretty yeah but the only
reason i got it was because of sports
oh that's right lacrosse yeah you did
yeah i didn't know you played lacrosse
at harvard yeah
dude we talked about it and you reacted
just like
did i you know i played a little
lacrosse in college as well
did you really division three every
community college widening university
yeah okay
my brother oh did you see how high his
voice went don't know it
sounds awesome ah that's great were you
in the skull and bones too
hit the bricks
[Laughter]
wait i didn't know that what position
did you play defenseman
nice yeah nice what about you i was a
midfielder yeah but you were
kid's got a body on them
i didn't know that that's crazy hmm
we'll have to talk shop after the
podcast
relax maybe grab a beer hang out
you show up in your old jersey get one
of them iced coffees
you keep talking about dropping this
beer
francis next one's on me pound it
it's like dude your hands stink that's
all they just
when you got a good pair of gloves that
[ __ ] that fit in like you know you
broke them in
yeah man they were they felt like
extensions of your body that's it
all right let's do this one okay this
will be the last one this one's from
jose
have have you or someone in your family
ever returned an item from a store
because it went on sale right after you
bought it
so you returned it so you could buy it
at the sale price i did that
really yeah but foley had an answer i
didn't mean that no no please
that's straight out of my mother's
[ __ ] playbook yeah yeah that's crazy
and it feels
really good when when you get it down
really yeah
because you go in guns blazing
you're like dude i swear to god i bought
a coat a nice
long coat uh that was like cool and
tailored and all this [ __ ] from this
store and
i i asked them as i was buying it this
is the kind of store where they give you
a beer as you're shopping
oh really yeah the name of it rag and
bone oh holy
shout out yeah it's nice and i walked in
there i saw this coat it was not as
expensive as i would have thought
looking at it it was really nice
and i walked up and i was like i love
this uh
but do you their stuff goes on sale all
the time
and i was like promise me this is not
going on sale
tomorrow and they're like this is part
of our fall line
it's not going on sale he's been flying
off the shelves and i was like all right
i bought it i'm not kidding you a week
later
half off how did you know that yeah i
told you i don't get because i get their
email
[ __ ] junk mail newsletters and i s
right up front there's my coat
did you have the person still no i'd
warn it and you say what do you take
what are they i walked back to the store
with the coat the very people had given
me my peroni
and i was like oh try to butter me up
with your imports i was like you looked
me in the eye and told me this coat was
not going on sale
and they were like you're right and then
they did that they took it back
and then resold it to me for half the
price i like that because you're going
i think your mom does it under the guise
of i don't need this this doesn't fit
he's he's going i made them i made them
give me stand by their words
yes i'm trying to [ __ ] pull one over
at boss
yeah no she'll um if she wants something
now
and she knows it's going on sale feels
like a memorial day sale
she'll buy it wear it and then go back
and be like yo
it's on sale let's go cut the chat god
jesus christ she might have had a
function or something she had though she
had to wear it needed it for
yeah oh i don't know that that's not
gonna be new jeans for a wedding
or a funeral
francis alice thank you so much can i i
have i have
one that i want to ask you guys or is
yours you guys have done so many
many episodes that i i worry that uh
anything i might bring
has already been covered so forgive me
if this is old believe it or not
probably not go ahead
have you ever brushed your teeth
while you were taking a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
never
never on the toilet i just started doing
it in the shower
i'm not that much of a go-getter why did
you do that i've done it yeah why
and then you gotta you gotta tuck your
junk while you spit
into the toilet no dude that's crazy
i think we just found the clip i don't
do it often i don't do it often but i've
done it and like in a pinch you got to
get out of the house
multi-task you guys got the apartment on
fire you can shave a couple of seconds
yeah but you know i gotta get that
sunscreen on my face gotta hit the
peloton you know
that's real brown behavior so we got
oops the podcast yeah you got the
patreon what else you got
check out the patreon i do i do uh sort
of shorter versions like uh
highlight clips from the alternate side
parking on my instagram
with the hope that people will enjoy
those enough to fork over five dollars a
month
uh but yeah check check me out if you
like these guys i'm similar
you similar type of humor yeah and
you're oops the podcast is with julio
who was a previous guest as well so good
job
who we also love happy birthday big guy
yeah heard it was his birthday
kp what do you got for him uh as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video on youtube and then
patreon.com
also guys live shows we have live shows
coming up in atlantic city
uh chicago we added a fourth [ __ ]
show that tickets
that's gonna [ __ ] sell out get fourth
and final and then indy as well
and uh we have more we have about 15
more coming so yeah
stay tuned we love you guys and we'll
see you next week